we have so much going on we got to move
on here so this is big star trek fans
the ultimate experience is happening at
the rio this weekend we've got autograph
signings seminars cosplay and this
year's convention is extra special take
a look the 55-year mission tour look at
this has arrived in las vegas and it is
a celebration because star trek creator
gene roddenberry would be 100 years old
this summer now here to tell us about
the event and about his father is rod
roddenberry i'm sorry captain how are
you captain i'm doing just good yeah
thank you for the great chair here i
appreciate you you have the captain i do
have the captain's chair it's kind of
nice here where are we tell everyone
where the setting is here uh you are on
the bridge of the original series
enterprise ncc 1701 this is it's
incredible anyone that comes down here
to the rio this weekend can take
pictures and see this this is a fan
favorite and this room is usually packed
they've given us a few moments in here
right now to get it to ourselves and
considering who i am you think i'd get
to do this more often i don't so it's
really nice for you to be in here yeah
because and i don't know if i need to be
the captain no no you can't wait
you're a legacy you're the captain of
this [ __ ] okay you might be in trouble
now your father would be turning 100
years old this august what would you
like people to do to celebrate his
legacy on his birthday which is august
19th it's august 19th um so listen
there's those of you out there who know
star trek and not everyone does star
trek had a message in it and had this
idea of a better future where we no
longer fear the difference between us
but we we thirst we craved for it we
knew that's how we grew intellectually
as a species and to do that you need to
have empathy and love for your common
man and woman and uh if there was one
thing i would say we should all do
there's a lot of great people out there
but let's let's take this day and let's
do something nice for someone something
you wouldn't normally do i think it
would just be great for our fellow
humans to take one day and there's a lot
of great people but do something a
little extra nice for someone i love it
yeah it fits with star trek it certainly
does it certainly does let's take a walk
around the bridge i'll follow you here
absolutely your father a
an icon and with star trek he started
the whole thing but you growing up you
were not a fan of the show at first no
so uh
i i might have taken a little while to
evolve intellectually myself some would
argue i'm not even there yet but um i i
was a knight rider starsky and hutch
dukes of hazzard yes and listen i i
loved star wars i saw it in the theater
i saw it over and over in the theater
yeah you loved star you were a star wars
fan first i was a star wars fan first
and it took me quite a while to really
understand what fans loved about star
trek but then i started talking to the
fans yes and they started telling these
incredible stories of how star trek had
impacted their lives in a positive way
whether they came from a a community
where they weren't inspired to do great
things but then they saw star trek and
they realized that they could actually
be a doctor or a teacher or something
like that and they're just so incredible
the fans are doing great things and this
is happening all weekend here at the rio
you can come down here
there's all kinds of uh there's
autograph signings there's a huge lego
display that we'll show you later on in
the four o'clock hour it's all happening
at the rio ron roddenberry the son of
gene roddenberry thank you so much for
joining us appreciate it live long and
prosper
oh i'm not